- [Instructor] In biology, it's useful
to have some shared language
so we can communicate and
describe the world around us
in ways that we can all
understand together.
So here, we're going to
talk about populations,
communities, and ecosystems.
And as we will see, these
are all related ideas.
So first of all, a population
is talking about the members
of a specific species in an area.
So for example, in this picture,
we have a population of zebra.
I have one zebra there, one zebra there,
there might be some
others that we can't see.
In fact, there are likely to be.
So, these are each members
of a population of zebra.
Now, we have other
populations in this picture.
We have a population of buffalo.
These three are members
of that population.
We have a population of antelope.
In fact, there is a bunch
of antelope in this picture.
So, we have many members
of that population.
We even see some animals
here in the background.
I can't quite make out what they are,
but that could be a different population.
Let's say if those are elephants,
they might be elephants
the way I see them,
but that could be members of
a population of elephants.
So if that is a population,
what is a community?
Well, a community is all
of the living species
that live in the same area.
So, we have a community of animals
that is made up of populations of buffalo,
of zebra, and of antelope.
And I wanna make clear
that the populations
or when we're talking
about the communities,
we're not necessarily just talking
about large animals like this.
We could be talking about
populations of mosquitoes.
populations of fish in this pond,
if there are any fish.
We could have a population of
a certain species of plant.
And likewise, when we're
talking about communities,
we're talking about collectively
all of the living organisms together.
Now, last but not least, what
would be an ecosystem then?
Well, an ecosystem is all
of the living organisms
plus all of the non-living things.
So, the ecosystem that we see here
would also include the water,
it would also include the dirt,
it would also include the air.
And organisms like those
that we see right here
are constantly interacting
with both the living
and nonliving parts of their environment.
These interactions are
how organisms get food,
shelter, water, and warmth.
These interactions are
how organisms survive
and produce offspring.
So, let's get a little bit more practice
with this idea of populations,
communities, and ecosystems.
And we will do that by
looking at this picture
right over here.
Pause this video and think about
what are the populations here?
Well, you might not know the name
of all these different types of fish,
but you can see that there's a population
of this gold-colored fish right over here.
There's also another population
of this blue-colored fish.
We could keep looking
for other populations.
It looks like there's a
population of this silver-colored
or I guess long-ish silver
fish right over here.
But once again, it's not just the fish.
There's a population of coral,
there's populations of microorganisms
that we can't see here.
The community would be all
of these living organisms
that live close to each other.
And we'll see, sometimes
they compete with each other,
sometimes they eat each other,
but sometimes they help each other,
Or sometimes they don't matter
that much to each other.
And we'll study that in a lot more detail.
And then the ecosystem
includes all of the above
plus the water, plus the
oxygen that is in the water,
plus the sand at the bottom of the ocean.
So, I'll leave you there.
Hopefully, you now have a sense
of what biologists are talking about
when they talk about populations,
communities, and ecosystems.